i hope i have lots of
romance and sex in this next one
jennifer coolidge is putting a few
things on her wish list for season two
of the white lotus i felt like i didn't
get enough of that in the first one i'm
not picky the actress is returning for
the upcoming season of the hit hbo
series which comes as no surprise
because jennifer received rave reviews
for her performance in season one
onion and i know it
i want you to get out of here and save
yourself when et caught up with jennifer
at the 2021 gotham awards she opened up
about the series's massive popularity
you know it really did it didn't matter
where i was this year
i mean it didn't matter that i had a
mask on i could be in a motorboat up in
maine like going by another speed boat
and so it'd be like wide load i mean it
was it was weird like everyone saw it
everyone saw that thing and um so that's
pretty exciting like it didn't you know
i mean i felt like
um that's the most popular thing i think
i've ever done where people just came
out of the woodwork you know and
and like
yeah everyone
saw that that show it's so exciting
jennifer's work is recognized not only
by the fans but by her peers as well on
monday night she was nominated at the
gotham awards for her performance as
tanya and shared with et what the nod
means to her it's such an honor you know
um i've never been nominated or
i've been never never and not only that
you know um i think people in new york
i haven't had a better waitressing
career than an acting career here
so i'm i was a waitress in new york for
many years so i'm so glad i get to come
as an actress but there's another role
she also gets a lot of recognition for a
girl like you can't hold on to her man
then there's sure as hell isn't any hope
for the rest of us
what are you waiting for
jennifer spilled what she knows about
the highly anticipated next installment
legally blonde three
i've heard just through the grapevine
that mindy kaling is like almost
finished or they finish it she and her
partner have finished it which is
absolutely great i think that's true i
don't i don't know for sure but i've
they haven't passed it to me yet um
but i get encouraging you know
texts and dms from rhys so
that something's happening something's
in the it's happening i think so you
bend
and snap
see
come on you try